ea montreront en seine-et-marne le maire
a voulu faire participer les jeunes à
ces cérémonies du 11 novembre
il a demandé aux professeurs de musique
d'apprendre la marseillaise aux jeunes
des quartiers dits difficiles ce matin
il connaissait les paroles par coeur
mais il y avait quelques lacunes en
histoire ou à la vanille sion et pierre
braskem ils ont entre 8 et 10 ans et
depuis trois semaines s'entraîne à
chanter la marseillaise sous la
direction d'un professeur de
conservatoire 250 gamins des cités de
montereau surville quartiers difficiles
multiethnique situées en plaine ac pour
la première fois aujourd'hui ils
participent à la cérémonie officielle du
11 novembre
mais s'ils connaissent par coeur l'hymne
national leur notion de l'histoire sont
encore un peu confuse des morts
l'arrivée à lisieux
14 18 la révolution quand je leur ai
demandé ce que c'était que la
marseillaise peut aimer satin qui m'ont
répondu c'est quelqu'un c'est une femme
qui habite marseille d'autres qui m'ont
répondu c'est un chant qui viennent
marseille et puis d'autres qui m'ont
répondu bah c'est la musique du football
samba et du sport zéro pointé pour
l'histoire 10 sur 10 pour le cours
d'instruction civique grandeur nature
dans une ville comme seuls deux d'entre
eux on parle beaucoup d'intégration on a
des populations qui sont de diverses
origines apprendre aux enfants à chanter
la marseillaise et associé de 150
enfants aux cérémonies patriotiques
c'est un acte d'intégration fort qui est
symbolique mais qui est fort des enfants
qui aujourd'hui en tout cas on sait
moins aux poilus cas bien poser leur
voix